today's fast changing Digital World
keeping our online stuff safe is super
important more and more often bad people
trying to break into our computers and
steal our secrets that's why there are
people called cyber security genius and
ethical hackers they are like online
superheroes so in this video we will
learn about cyber security engineers and
ethical hackers and understand the
difference between them in this video we
will cover topics like who is a cyber
security engineer who is an ethical
hacker difference between the cyber
security engineer and ethical hacking
based on various measures Like rules
production environment reporting client
usage problem solving average salary and
companies hiring for them but before we
begin let me ask you a quick question so
what is the main purpose of a firewall
in a network security setup all right so
first option is to block all incoming
and outgoing Network traffic option b is
to allow and restricting access to the
network option C is to filter and
control Network traffic based on a set
of rules and option D is to provide
encryption for data in transit now you
can pause this video and answer in the
comment section below alright so let's
start with the first topic which is who
is a cyber security engineer so cyber
security engineer is a professional
dedicated to securing an organization
digital infrastructure systems and data
they are responsible for implementing
robust security measures and
safeguarding the organization against
cyber threats vulnerabilities anal decks
cyber security Engineers work
proactively to prevent breaches and
ensure that information remains
confidential available and integral in
other words cyber security Engineers is
like a digital Guardian for a company
they work to make sure that all the
digital stuff like computers networks
and data is safe from bad people who
want to steal or damage them so this is
what a cyber security engineer is all
right now let's understand who is is a
ethical hacker so an ethical hacker on
the other side often called as a
whitehead hacker is an individual with
specialized skills in penetration
testing and vulnerability assessment
organizations hire ethical hackers to
simulate cyber attacks and identify
vulnerabilities in their systems and
networks they operate under ethical
guidelines helping organization
strengthen their security by uncovering
weaknesses before malicious hackers can
exploit them so to put in a simple words
an ethical hacker is a good guy who acts
like a bad guy but for a good reason
they are hired by companies to pretend
to be a bad hacker and try to break into
their systems why because by doing this
they can find the weak points in the
company's defenses and help them fix
before the real bad guys find them so
this is what an ethical hacker do for a
company so this was about who is an
ethical hacker now let's understand the
difference between cyber security
engineer and ethical hacker based on
various measures so first we will
understand the difference between an
ethical hacker and a cyber security
engineer based on their rules all right
so cyber security Engineers are
responsible for Designing and
implementing security measures whereas
ethical hackers simulate real world
cyber attacks to identify
vulnerabilities cyber security Engineers
establish security policies and
protocols ensuring compliance with
industry standards and regulations the
ethical hacker primary goal is to find
weaknesses that malicious hackers could
exploit cyber security Engineers or
professionals manage firewalls intrusion
detection and encryption mechanisms
whereas ethical hackers use various
tools and techniques to test the
security of systems and networks cyber
security Engineers monitor Network
traffic and systems for science of
unauthorized access or suspicious
activity whereas on the other hand
ethical hackers provide detailed reports
outlining discovered vulnerabilities and
recommended remediation steps the cyber
security engineer respond to security
incidents conducting investigations and
implementing corrective measures on the
other hand ethical hackers work helps
organizations proactively enhance their
security posture so these were some of
the differences between a cyber security
engineer and an ethical hacker also if
you want to become a cyber security
expert look no further introducing our
postgraduate program in cyber security
your gateway to mastering comprehensive
strategies for safeguarding
infrastructure and fortifying data delve
into risk analysis mitigation techniques
and compliance practices that are
Paramount in today's digital landscape
from foundational principle to Advanced
methodologies this program offers an
array of industry-leading cyber security
certification courses that from the
backbone of your journey equip yourself
with expertise td2 thrive in the
ever-evolving realm of cyber security
and roll now and pave the way for a
secure digital future alright now coming
to the second point of distinction
between a cyber security engineer
ethical hacker that is production
environment so cyber security engineer
typically work in a production
environment where they Implement and
maintain security measures whereas
ethical hackers operate in a controlled
testing environment cyber security
Engineers focus on ensuring the
day-to-day security of an organization
system and networks whereas ethical
hackers perform security assessments and
penetration tests in a sandbox
environment minimizing risk to
production environment cyber security
Engineers work involves constant
monitoring patching and system hardening
to prevent attacks on the other hand
ethical hackers work is geared towards
uncovering vulnerabilities without
disrupting normal operations
so this was the difference between cyber
security engineer and ethical hacker
based on production environment moving
on to the next point of Distinction
which is reporting client usage so cyber
security Engineers collaborate with
various departments within an
organization whereas ethical hackers
primarily report to clients including
IIT and securities teams cyber security
Engineers report to management and may
interact with legal and compliance teams
whereas ethical hackers communication
evolves around delivering detailed
reports of vulnerabilities discovered
during testing cyber security Engineers
communication is often focused on
maintaining ongoing security and
addressing security incidents ethical
hackers provide actionable insights to
improve security all right so this was
the difference between cyber security
engineer and ethical hacker based on
reporting client usage how they report
all right coming to the next point which
is problem solving so cyber security
Engineers are proactive problem solvers
focusing on preventive measures where as
ethical hackers are reactive problem
solvers concentrating on identifying and
mitigating existing vulnerabilities
cyber security Engineers analyze the
security landscape accesses risk and
design Security Solutions whereas
ethical hackers devise creative ways to
exploit weaknesses and provide
recommendations for remediation cyber
security Engineers role involves
continuous monitoring and adaption to
involving like evolving threats whereas
ethical hackers strive to thinking like
attackers they actually have to think
like attackers to uncover the hidden
vulnerabilities so this was the
difference between a cyber security
engineer and an ethical hacker based on
problem solving now coming to the next
point which is average salary so cyber
security engineer the average salary for
a cyber security engineer is 121
thousand dollars whereas the average
salary for an ethical hacker is around
000 per year in United States
so this is how much a cyber security
engineer and ethical hacker can earn so
if you want to become a cyber security
engineer or an ethical hacker you can
opt for a postgraduate program in cyber
security by simply learn also listen to
what a Learners has to say about this
course hi I'm Philip I am 61 years old
and last year I upskill was simply
learns postgraduate program in cyber
security after working 30 years in the
IIT sector in various different profiles
I'm happy to tell you that I was able to
clear and pass my cissp and ccsp
certification exams on the first attempt
after taking the course of course I must
say was packed with practical examples
it was led by highly skilled certified
instructors with many companies before
the security analysts and the architect
on a contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with Infosys as a cyber
security consultant happened on the
first
all right now
movies hiding so there are many
companies that are hiring for ethical
hackers and cyber security engineers in
penetration testers so there are a lot
of companies out there but some of the
well-known companies that we'll mention
over here is first one is Tesla hacker
rank Lenovo test Google unisoft
Technologies cryptomize
Etc please keep in mind that other than
these companies there are a lot of
companies in India and in U.S all over
the world which are hiring for ethical
hackers and cyber security Engineers so
there are vast sector it is a very huge
sector where you can add value and and
make a lot of money out of it so these
were some of the differences between a
cyber security engineer and an ethical
hacker so in conclusion cyber security
engineers and ethical hackers contribute
to the security of digital ecosystem but
their rules and responsibilities and
focus areas differ significantly cyber
security Engineers are responsible for
maintaining and enhancing security
measures whereas ethical hackers play a
crucial role in identifying the
vulnerabilities through control testing
the collaboration of these two rules is
essential in ensuring comprehensive
cyber security for organizations in an
increasingly like complex digital world
so all right guys with that we have come
to the end of this video If you like
this video please give it a thumbs up I
hope it will help you all thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here